two great Talks by Evan Sadler and ASU
asadogler and now today this afternoon
we're going to have one final talk
s and so do you want to start sharing
your screen and then after Dean talks
for people who are physically in
Berkeley
and how we're going to organize lunch
tables so that like you don't have to be
alone even if you're joining from here
hotels
first let's hear from D and D is going
to talk about long ties formation social
contagion and economic outcomes so go
ahead
cool um yeah thanks for having me be
part of this
um I mean uh I I knew that this program
was happening at Simon's and and right
now this Academic Year I'm on sabbatical
and I'm in uh Europe and Berlin right
now so um you know wasn't really able to
you know uh
be part of it if if it was gonna be in
person so it's great to be part of this
virtual event
so um I was going to present uh kind of
some related a couple related things
that are all connected by the notion of
long ties where what we mean here by
long ties are uh Connections in a social
network where the two nodes that are
being connected don't have any network
Neighbors in common right they don't
have any Mutual uh ties right and so um
those long ties could then uh be
important for all kinds of things like
the spread of information or disease or
behaviors and then could have cascading
effects for things like economic
Prosperity so the work I'm going to talk
about depending on how much time I end
up having is related to these three uh
different papers
um and really when I'm going to spend
the most time on is the second one which
is kind of um
sort of like a network Theory slash
applied probability slash maybe applied
Game Theory kind of paper in in some
ways but we also have some empirical
work that maybe is interesting uh and
that's the first and third papers and I
think talking about the first one will
help to set up some of the ideas we
might have about
um about long ties and their importance
overall so
um
and I I think also um the first author
of the first paper Iman jahani uh is uh
currently a postdoc and lecturer at um
at UC Berkeley and I think he's uh
presenting some of our other work
together during the poster session so um
you for those of you in person you could
uh connect with uh with him
so um uh kind of to set the stage what
do I mean by long ties and what are
what's kind of the history of that
Concept in a social sciences
um strong ties strong ties are ones that
are you know involve a lot of time a lot
of emotional intensity intimacy
reciprocal exchange maybe they're high
bandwidth in some sense there's a lot of
information that can be transferred via
strong ties to people that you you trust
a lot Etc right those are more likely to
be embedded in closed Triads so the
people that you're you know have the
highest trust with that you have to
spend the most time with it's unusual if
those people are not people that you
share other contacts with right
um actually I think um some work by
Backstrom and kleinberg highlighted some
years ago that one of the best ways to
figure out
um uh who somebody's uh significant
other is on Facebook is to look at uh
what's the edge that's most embedded and
they have some fancier measures as well
but that gets you a lot of the way there
what's the edge that really you know has
the most Mutual ties and actually has
the most Mutual ties across a lot of
different communities right so that's
that's sort of a fact about strong ties
is that strong ties are also usually in
these closed Triads on the other hand
weak ties ones where there isn't a ton
of time there's not necessarily these
are sort of like arms length
relationships
um these are more likely to be part of
open Triads uh that is that uh you know
it could be that
um here in this picture at the bottom
left which is from a classic paper by
Grana better
um A and B are connected right but um B
and C are not connected and in fact
there's there's no one uh who is a
mutual friend or Mutual Network neighbor
of A and B right so weak ties are sort
of more likely to be part of these open
Triads so that's not their definition or
definition usually is in terms of these
things like time intensity bandwidth
trust Etc right
um and there's this idea that structural
diversity or having connections uh to a
bunch of different local communities
having a bunch of these long ties could
you give you information advantages
um could expose you to more sources of
Novel information faster earlier Etc
um so this is kind of the the
intellectual space that we're working in
here and and asking these kinds of
questions so do disease information and
behavior spread more rapidly through
more clustered networks left where there
aren't such long ties or more random
networks like on the right where there
actually there's a lot of long ties
right a lot of the the edges here uh are
ones that have you know no embeddedness
that have zero embeddedness they're
local Bridges what local network
structures are advantageous for
individuals and communities
um how do people end up with these
different sorts of network structures
why is it that some people have uh more
along times than other people and what
sorts of changes to network structure
would accelerate the spread of
contagions in networks
um and really I'm going to focus most on
on this first and last question but
briefly mention first some uh uh some
empirical work that we've done right so
this is kind of the program and then I'm
going to say a little bit about long
ties in the United States and Mexico
um and kind of where they come from and
then spend a bit more time talking about
how long ties uh can uh play a role in
in the spread of threshold-based
contagions okay so first this empirical
part this is work that's
um
uh we did in collaboration with Michael
Bailey at Facebook this is um also with
Iman jahani and and Sam Freiburger
um at the World Bank
um uh but uh we're we're looking at a
network uh connecting users on Facebook
and so we're going to focus on a network
uh that's defined by Mutual exchange of
comments between people on Facebook so
this isn't just the Facebook network of
people who say they're friends with each
other right but it's a sparse your
network and also a network that's going
to have tie strength information
associated with it so there's an edge
between users inj if they've
reciprocally exchanged comments during a
six-month period okay so this is
um uh then we can actually use how many
comments they exchange traditionally as
a measure of Thai strength and then we
and then we can get um you know estimate
for most people uh where they live in
the US or Mexico
um and that's going to be important for
doing things like measuring
um uh that the prevalence of different
kinds of network structures in
particular places and so
um did you want me to interrupt with
questions that people sure sure so Ben
asks uh does this include comments like
on a political post strangers are going
to make each other on the internet
uh so this is these are these are
subsets of the declared friendship ties
I think I should maybe clarify that so
so
um uh it could be that there's a there's
a public political post by a political
figure and then I comment on it and then
you reply to it and if we're Facebook
friends that would count even though
it's not on a post by either one of us
but it is this subset of the French
impacts yeah great thanks
um so um a lot of the analysis that we
do with this is actually at the
individual level to avoid issues of
ecological you know ecological fallacies
but um I think the the geographically
aggregated level helps to provide a lot
of intuitions and the results end up
being quite similar and it allows us to
make some pretty Maps so I'm going to
start with the geographically aggregated
version so nodes within a region have
ties to other nodes in that region and
also to nodes outside of that region and
we can say just of all ties that involve
the nodes in some region like a zip code
what fraction are long ties we're here
to spell this out long ties are ties
without Mutual neighbors these are
sometimes called local Bridges and we'd
say that they have Edge embeddedness
zero
um and so we can just look at what is
the the
um uh fraction of long ties look like
across U.S counties here's aggregated up
to the county level and this is after
partialing out average degree because uh
just how many connections people have is
quite related uh to this fraction of
long ties and so um here here we see you
know that that some places in the U.S
just have a lot more of these long ties
than others and um so notably you might
look at say Appalachia and notice that
Appalachia has a very low fraction of
long ties
um whereas in a bunch of places kind of
uh you know wealthy suburbs Etc have a
lot of loan ties in general I'm not sure
the American West has a lot of long ties
by comparison okay you can similarly
look at this for Mexico
um depending on your knowledge of the US
versus Mexico this might also allow you
to think about some of these specific
places
in some of the places with indeed the
lowest levels of long ties in Mexico are
also
um uh uh you know economically not so
prosperous
um so uh you can then think about okay
this is just this prevalence of these
long ties and we asked two questions in
this paper uh one is like what are some
life events that we think might create
these long Tides
um both directly and help people perhaps
develop the skill to form these long
ties and then uh art is having these
long ties associated with
um economic outcomes right part of the
theory coming from this Rich Work in
sociology is that this is these long
times would give people access to a
whole bunch of additional information
and opportunities that they wouldn't
have if they have a network that
consists of much more closed Triads
rather than this kind of open structure
um so uh we do look at how um in the
paper we focus a lot more on the
individual level outcomes but I'll just
again show that the geographically
aggregated version here just looking at
how the economic outcomes for a zip code
in the United States depends on
the fraction of long ties uh in that
place
um controlling for a bunch of other
things like degree and population
Etc right so this is what these typical
results look like here is that
um places uh with a higher fraction of
these long ties so more of the ties that
involve the people
in that place don't have mutual
neighbors uh the higher uh median
household income we have and these
results we have very similar results for
um unemployment lower unemployment with
a higher fraction of long ties and all
kinds of other thresholds on income
intergenerational Mobility is also
higher in these places for this higher
fraction of long time
um do you have any way to
do you have any way to claim causality
here
uh no no I would I would say that we
want to be kind of careful about that
that
um that I would assume that there's
actually causal processes running in
both directions right uh long ties can
kind of be expensive to maintain right
one way to you know maintain uh a long
tie is to you know see that person in
person and they might you know long ties
are not defined geographically in our
definition but they're more likely to be
farther away geographically it also can
be that say um you know if you have a
bunch of people with you know that are
all connected to each other you can do
something like have dinner with all of
them at once or have a social gathering
at one of their homes right and everyone
is sort of Welcome in that setting
whereas long ties might be more
expensive to maintain maybe I need in
terms of time and money
right I might need to
um actually have dinner with these
people separately in if we're going out
to dinner maybe that's expensive or we
have to sort of arrange things so that
we're having social Gatherings that kind
of are appropriate uh in that way so
um so I I think causality kind of runs
in both directions and that you know
we're not uh we're not looking at you
know the fraction of long ties that
formed in some earlier prior period and
looking at these later outcomes I mean
especially with
um economic Mobility right some of those
economic Mobility events are happening
prior probably to some of these
relationships even for me so
um so yeah I'd say this is this what we
find to be a very robust Association
whether it's at the aggregated level or
um at the individual level and using a
whole bunch of different um uh kind of
outcomes we measure
um but uh yeah we don't think that this
result is something that we would
contribute you to you know a causal
relationship a single cause of
relationship but I think it's actually
even interesting and in some of our
other work together Iman jahani and I
have have worked uh on this is thinking
about what what are the causal effects
of network structure what kinds of
interventions do you actually have in
mind right because if I were to say oh
but I wanted to claim that yes
increasing diffraction of long ties is
going to increase median household
income what is what am I even saying
there right like what kinds of possible
interventions to network structure do I
have in mind right
um you know one way to increase your
fraction of long ties is to make two of
your friends have a falling out with
each other
right
um is that beneficial I don't think so
really like
um so so we want to have particular
kinds of ways of changing the network
structure in mind yeah
um so one one of the things that I
mentioned earlier right is this idea
that a lot of times weak ties have been
kind of thought of as as just another
name for long ties and vice versa right
but we really think of it as that it's
the long ties that are kind of important
here right now long ties happen to be
more likely to be weak than you know
short ties strong ties are likely to be
short right but um it could be that you
give more of your attention or time or
emotional intensity is directed at uh
people that you don't have uh you know
Common uh Network neighbors with
and the chat asks are there gender and
or age differences in these patterns
um yeah so yes there there are some um
some of those differences um a lot of
those things are also um you know
related to degree so people of different
ages have accumulated different numbers
of friends uh in the United States in
particular women have higher degree on
Facebook than men do
um and so then that is really closely
related to these outcomes and I'll show
later briefly uh a slide that shows how
strongly related uh to degree uh these
measures are but um in a lot of what we
do we're able to at least do things like
match on age and gender
um but we don't specifically uh study
that as a source of variation here is
more as a nuisance I guess
um
yeah
um and we'll see that we we look at a
couple kind of Life events that and so
you can see how people could accumulate
these ties over time
um so so we really want to say that it's
the long ties that are predictive and in
fact if you could
um put more intensity more bandwidth on
the long ties
um therefore you know kind of breaking
the weak Thai Long tie Association in
some sense uh that could be beneficial
or at least it could be predictive of
these uh better outcomes
and so we see that actually it even
conditional on the fraction of long ties
in a place the weighted fraction of
volunteers that is weighted by the
number of comments that are exchanged on
that tie is also further predictive of
median household income in the same
direction right so uh conditional just
how many long ties you have if more of
your attention more of your interaction
is allocated to those long ties that's
also associated with better economic
outcomes okay and and this also holds at
the individual level
um so uh here in the six largest states
in the U.S if you look at the fraction
of long edges this is associated with
both people's um uh ZIP code uh level uh
median income but also some other
proxies for economic Prosperity like how
many different devices they use uh to
access Facebook
um
similar results for also the
um uh the price of the main mobile phone
that they use
um also how many donations they make
using Facebook's donation product or
even donate to Charities and to and
directly to people
um and and a similar thing applies for
the weighted fraction of long ties so
um uh basically we find this you know
robust empirical association between
whether it's individual level or zip
code level Network structure the
presence of these long ties and the
stronger long ties and economic
Prosperity so yeah I I wouldn't want to
claim that this is
um you know this kind of simple
unidirectional causal relationship but
this is kind of a robust
um uh correlation that we think
um is an important stylized fact to
consider and further uh further study as
well
also it's not kind of the only thing in
the picture right I think earlier um
Nicole referred to these recent pair of
papers in nature by um by Matt Jackson
and Ross Chetty and others um and that
looks at one other kind of uh Network
structure measure that is quite related
to economic outcomes and Mobility which
is the degree to which
um people who are lower income and
higher income uh or lower SES and higher
SES are connected
um through the Facebook Network we might
think that actually a bunch of these
long ties that people have are more
likely to be those sorts of SES
spanning ties as well so just to say a
little bit more about about this one of
the things we thought was interesting is
where do these ties come from right so
why do people have more or less of these
ties
um so we looked at three life events
that people can have that are all kind
of disruptive life events right that are
all changes you can think of these as
Mobility uh events or my migration
events
um people who migrate between states or
attend college in or out of state I
don't have time to go into all of them
I'm just going to focus on people
attending multiple high schools okay so
um
part we think is a nice one because
people who who
um change high schools maybe don't make
that choice for themselves their parents
might be making it might be made for
various ways reasons that are sort of
somewhat out of their control so we've
got people who are aged between 60 and
uh 30 and 60 and have some of the
available data who either lists a single
high school or two high schools in their
profile
and um uh we we match on age gender
Hometown County Income
um and people who attend multiple high
schools have 10 more in relative terms
long ties relative to those who attended
a single high school
um this is true at basically all levels
of degree if you stratify by degree how
many total connections they have you can
see on the right here that just the long
ties for Action is just always higher
than the people who attended multiple
high schools if we try to eliminate all
the ties that are associated with either
of these high schools you also still see
this pattern right so the idea that we
have in mind is not just at this event
maybe is immediately producing more long
ties but that also it's potentially
um uh helping people to develop a
disposition to form more long ties in
the future
um one thing we're able to do with this
that I haven't added to the slides here
yet is that we actually look at a kind
of exogenous event that occurs where um
uh possibly exogenous at least where a
school closes and if you look at the
people uh you know in kind of a
different diff set up just before and
after a school closes the people who uh
were exposed to that closure also have a
higher fraction of long ties so again
there could be various sources of kind
of confounding here but we think that
you know even in that kind of a case
um that it's interesting that this
Association persists okay
so
um you know given those those results
um this is kind of consistent with this
whole broad story about the idea that
long ties structurally diverse networks
are advantageous for people because they
give them access to information and
opportunities Etc right
um
so
um it seems useful to think about how
does that square with the kind of models
that we use to
um
to think about the spread of information
and behavior in networks okay so if we
think about like what's sometimes called
a simple contagion this is a model where
um if uh if someone is infected with a
disease or has some information
that they're going to pass that to each
of their neighbors with some probability
and so that means that if I have some
number X of uh infected neighbors my
probability of becoming infected in the
next round are preceding some
information in the next round is some
kind of sublinear function of the the
number of adopting or infected or
information having neighbors okay so
then in this kind of setup
um uh these contagions are just pretty
straightforwardly accelerated by doing
things like rewiring a network if you
start with a really clustered Network
like a lattice and you just do random
rewiring of edges that's going to speed
up these sorts of contagions
um so long ties accelerate these kinds
of simple contagions uh you know we're
all sort of familiar with idea now right
that in the early stages of an epidemic
it can be a good idea to restrict travel
because some of that travels all about
long talks right
so long ties accelerate social
contagions too right but I think the
story in the literature has been a lot
more complex than that um coming from
kind of multiple uh prominent papers
um so um centola and Macy uh
sociologists say you know for complex
contagions
um which which they think are quite
prevalent too little clustering means
too few wide Bridges which not only
slows down Cascades but to prevent them
entirely
right uh montenari and saberi in pnas uh
say it appears that Innovation spreads
more slowly on well-connected network
structures dominated by long-range links
than by
um you know more clustered say
geographically clustered networks right
and what they have in mind in terms of
the the models of contagion here are
models where uh basically there's some
probability uh there's some threshold
above which I have very high probability
of adopting uh compared to below the
threshold where I have very low
probability of adopting it and generally
what they're studying here is is this
deterministic model where there's just
some threshold uh to or in general we'll
think of this being threshold as being
Theta above which I adopt and below that
threshold I don't adopt
so um now what we're gonna consider here
is cases where this threshold is not
entirely deterministic and see how this
kind of changes some of the landscape of
the results right so uh what we're
thinking about is you know this kind of
a model of Contagion on the right
um that could really be rationalized as
some kind of myopic best reply play in a
semi-anonymous graphical game with
strategic complements right so uh you
can imagine that I
um if I adopt I get uh some utility
that's proportional to the the number of
uh of uh neighboring adopters I have and
I'm playing some kind of my app I best
reply
so one thing to note is that there
doesn't really seem to be much evidence
for anything like a deterministic or
near-deterministic threshold in the
empirical literature okay so if you look
at the from empirical papers the
probability of someone adopting when
they have exactly K neighbors who are
adopters versus probably adopting when
they have K minus one adopt our
neighbors
um if there was like a clear threshold
in the data right or at least a
homogeneous threshold uh you should see
really large values of this ratio
somewhere right but it seems like the
largest values we see anywhere are like
four
um even in some of the work that's
actually argued for the importance of
these kind of threshold-based complex
contagions the threat the these ratios
are often under two for example if you
think of this
um this uh case uh from centola there's
just you know the ratio is actually
under two so it's really a sublinear
um kind of curve to some degree so I
think there's far from from being
evidence that there's that these
thresholds are kind of these really
homogeneous and deterministic kind of
thing so we're going to study a more
realistic model with a small probability
of adoption below the threshold you can
think of this as kind of noisy myopic
best reply Dynamics or that they're sort
of trembling hand adoptions happening
um in a bunch of the results we focus on
the case of a threshold at two right so
if I have two adopter neighbors and I
adopt and then if I don't have two if I
just have a single adopter neighbor
um I could adopt with probability two
um and Q is going to be some small value
um and actually we're sometimes going to
only allow that probability Q to happen
via some edges so so it'll only be
um some particular local Ties That Could
infect me with this probability Q
and we'll see that having uh Q uh
greater than 1 over square root of n is
enough to really change the landscape of
results that led to this idea that long
ties are weak uh for complex contagions
that are insufficient to facilitate
their spread
um so uh to give you a kind of tour of
our analytical results we're going to
look at time to spread of a
deterministic threshold based contagion
when random edges are added to a lattice
this is going to just help sort of fix
some ideas and provide some preliminary
results then we're going to think about
what happens if we're substituting
random edges for these clustered lattice
edges
um so um for the
for these analytical results we we use
these kinds of graphs so um a cycle
power K graph where you just have all
the nodes connected by a cycle and then
they're connected not just uh to their
immediate Neighbors in the cycle but to
uh further Neighbors on that right so in
in C2 you're connected to not just your
immediate neighbors but they're they're
neighbors as well
um then we're also going to think about
cycles that are are combined with a
random graph so um CK uh two over n is
going to be the union of CK and a random
graph with Edge probability two over n
okay so these are going to be kind of
like um small world networks they're not
exactly the watch strogas Network and
and there's also some versions of this
that are not exactly some other like
Newman Watts uh versions of this but
they're very similar to that but they
have some mathematical advantages for us
okay so
um let's just think about adding ties to
some cycle so we have C2 and we have
this this
um contagion with this threshold two
that's spreading on C2 from two initial
points okay so then we add some random
edges so maybe in this draw we just get
this one random match okay drawing this
one random Edge this could only reduce
time to spread even with a deterministic
threshold right because adding edges in
this kind of a model just only going to
speed things up so spread time on C2 is
order n it's got to just go around this
whole circle right whereas spread time
on on this network where we've added
some of these random edges can actually
occur with high probability much faster
than that okay to give you a sense of
how what are the mechanisms of spread
why is this happening intuitively
um there's going to be these two initial
adopter nodes and then things can spread
along the cycle okay and then eventually
the cycle is going to be large enough
that there's some other node that has
two edges to that infected cycle and
then it's going to pop over to that
place and this actual draw that happened
to also coincide with when there was
three edges to that section which is
maybe a little confusing but you know
usually it would be two edges right so
then the contagion jumps to this one
point and then it can potentially start
growing from there as well okay
um in the in the case that we still have
C2 in place it's going to grow just
through above threshold adoptions okay
but if we allow some below threshold
adoptions the idea that you could adopt
with probability Q
um even if you only have one adopter
neighbor then some of this spread along
the cycle is going to happen via these
uh low
um these below threshold adoptions so
starting from a pair of adjacent C1
neighboring infected nodes it's going to
take
um you know these
um uh no this is the result I just
showed you okay so but now I actually
want to replace the random the the
psychological random edges so what if we
go from C2 on the left to
um C1 Union with a random graph where
we're going to have the same uh same uh
expected number of edges same expected
degree Etc okay and so really this is
going to trade off two things one is
that
um we have to wait until these cycle
intervals get big enough
um and then once they're big enough uh
with high probability they're going to
start new intervals in other parts of
the graph
so um we can upper bound the spreading
Time by breaking down the contagion into
those two sub-processes
and so
um you know uh when is it going to
happen that with high probability there
is some uninfected node that has uh two
edges to one of these infected intervals
that's going to happen when an interval
is square root of n log log n nodes long
okay so that's helps give us you know
this sense of how how long do we have to
wait for these intervals to grow and
they're growing just through these below
threshold adoptions okay
so that then tells us that with high
probability that we're going to
um have this contagion spread to the to
the whole network when when n is large
um in less than this amount of time
and you can see that this depends on
this uh square root of n and q and so
when Q is larger than uh square root of
n
um then uh we're going to end up also
being uh asymptotically faster than the
spread in C2 where it's ordering
um you can see this also in simulations
as well so
um you know whether you do it with
exactly this kind of model that we
described or similar legit or probit
models
um
you can also do this with sort of
interpolating between C2 and C1 Union
with this random graph so maybe we want
to not just completely switch from C2 to
this like to C1 that with these random
edges which is much more random what
happens if we just sort of are making
smaller changes to the network structure
is that going to have the same effects
right and so we can do this by defining
this this network where we rewire
um uh some number of edges
um and we're still basically keeping the
the node degrees more or less the same
as we do this
um and so what we end up finding here is
you basically need to rewire enough if
you only rewire a few edges
um then you might break some of the
structure in C2 that's allowing this
contagion to spread uh around the the
network through this above threshold
adoptions while not creating enough long
ties that you're going to have these
long ties that you need for inner tools
to form new intervals in other far away
parts of the network
so um basically in this setup you need
uh to rewire at least half of the edges
right so you need to it you know get to
a sufficiently random Network we find
that in empirical Networks you're kind
of already random enough and so any real
changes to the network structure are
going to speed things up
everything I've said so far is about
um a contagion that doesn't reverse at
all right that once you adopt you remain
in the doctor
I think this is actually a pretty
important conceptual thing to think
about right
um some behaviors you kind of switch
back and forth between multiple
available behaviors at any time
um you know if if you're bilingual
depending on who you're talking with at
the moment you might switch between uh
speaking English or Spanish right and
you could just switch back relatively
costlessly sometimes this can get a
little tricky you might mix things up
right but like overall you can switch
pretty easily right once you learn
Spanish you don't have to only speak
Spanish for the rest of your life right
you can speak whatever uh other
languages you speak as well okay
um but for a lot of things that we study
in terms of the spread of behaviors
there's
um you know there's not just like
immediate Costless switching happening
right if I decide I'm going to buy a
hybrid car because everyone's getting
hybrid cars right and maybe there's a
better charging Network get an electric
car right
um
then uh uh then I don't just suddenly
the next day decide that I'm selling my
electric car
similarly if I decide to install
WhatsApp then I still have WhatsApp
installed it doesn't just sort of you
know go away I don't just reevaluate in
the next period okay so I think it makes
sense to have there be substantial
inertia in contagions where once
somebody uh adopts some Behavior or a
product maybe they stick with it for a
bit but they could revert uh with some
probability so if we allow the doctors
to revert with uh with a probability uh
Delta
um you can think of this as also upper
bounding the time if adopters just
reevaluate what they're going to do with
probably would probably really Delta
each period
um then generally we get the same
results that we had before
um except that Delta needs to be smaller
than one over square root of N and and
also it's really our results are going
to end up depending on uh the difference
between q and Delta so Q is this this
probability of adopting spontaneously
and so now we need Q minus Delta to be
larger than uh than uh square root of n
uh to get these results that these you
know more random networks are speeding
things up
um so I think this is actually kind of
just you know more generally interesting
point is that this question of this is
the contagion reversible or not
um doesn't come up if you think about
like the initial deterministic threshold
based Contagion
because no one ever has a reason
to change their decision right once you
adopt right it's just this Progressive
contagion uh and so even if somebody
reverts they're always going to make the
same decision
again in the next period if no one else
is also changing at the same time right
so whereas if you start to consider this
uh some kind of uh
non-deterministic process then this
becomes relevant and one of the things
that we realize in this is that uh some
of the prior work that I mentioned when
they have studied non-deterministic
um contagions of this kind of for these
threshold contagions uh they're always
perfectly reversible in that everybody
remakes their decision Anew in the next
period so if somebody who has only one
adopter neighbor adopts
right it's very likely that then in the
next period they're going to decide not
to adopt again because there's no
inertia in that process so it's part of
the reason that these earlier papers uh
by montanari and saberi and centola and
Macy I think find that oh their results
are robust to
um you know some kind of stochastic
aspect to this but it's always with no
inertia whatsoever
okay so
um
okay cool yeah so I was just gonna
conclude with showing some of this
applied to empirical networks so I'm
just going to do some simulations on a
whole bunch of different empirical
networks where we think about time to
spread under three interventions so
first we consider how long is the
contagion take this spread on the
original Network how long does it take
to spread if we do some random rewiring
or if we randomly add edges what if we
um randomly add edges that close open
Triads so that's like actually
preferring to add short ties right as
opposed to Long ties and um here I'm
just going to focus on a 10 intervention
where basically we're doing this to 10
of the original edges okay
um and we've allow below threshold
adoptions here with probability five
percent
um if that seems large to you you can
also think about the fact that if if
people don't actually adopt with
probability one above the threshold
really what matters is the ratio of this
probability above the threshold to the
one below the threshold so we're talking
about the below threshold probability
being you know a 20th right of the above
probability threshold
okay so the first set of networks that
I'll show you
um uh are these networks that maybe a
lot of people are familiar with which
are measured among um households in
rural villages in in China and edges
indicate
um that these are people who they
discuss farming and personal finance but
we're using the undirected version of
this network there's 175 of these
Villages okay so first just thinking
about the original villages
the original Village networks what if we
run this spreading process on them
um so here each of these lines is the
CDF of time to spread for one of the
villages and then I've normalized them
so that the mean spread time is one here
okay so we can see that you know some of
the villages things spread a little bit
faster or you know slower in but we've
removed that variation some of them have
a little bit more variance from
simulation run to simulation run and how
fast things spread okay now we're going
to consider some of these interventions
so what
if we rewire 10 of the edges at random
okay these curves basically all shift
Left Right we've just reduced the time
to spread okay so Random rewiring here
is speeding things up now this says that
you know to the extent that our
theoretical results are a good guide
here part of the idea is that these
networks were sort of already random
enough that a little bit of random
rewiring is moving Us in the right
direction right because we saw before
that um If you're sort of interpolating
between C2 say and um and this and C1
Union with this random graph you need to
be you know sort of halfway there
already for you know going more random
to help you so we're seeing here already
that just rewiring speeds things up
maybe it's more realistic to consider
interventions where we're adding ties
um you know I said before it's not like
we want to consider interventions where
we make you know your two friends have a
falling out with each other right or we
change the existing edges maybe it's
more about encouraging people to make
connections sort of along the lines of
some of the
um the random Squadron assignment stuff
that Evan was talking about
um you know this is this time when
people are arriving and forming
connections
um so what if we
um uh close Triad closing edges right so
we this these are adding short types
that's going to speed things up relevant
uh relative to the original networks
there's just more edges right but if we
were to add random edges that would
speed things up even more
okay so basically across these 175
networks
um uh if you look at the difference in
ecdfs you know the so for each of each
of these lines on the left is the
difference in the CDF for spread times
under
um uh adding random edges versus Triad
closing edges you basically have
stochastic dominance right adding random
edges rather than trying closing edges
is just shifting this distribution of
spread times lower to be faster for
pretty much all of these uh 175 networks
um and if you look at this across a
bunch of other collections of networks
you basically see similar patterns um
you know the magnitude of the effects
can can vary but it's it's the same
pattern across all of them that um
rewiring some of the edges or adding
random edges instead of adding Triad
closing edges is speeding up
um the spread so um
I think I'm pretty much out of time so
I'm just gonna
um kind of uh summarize by saying that I
think uh biological contagions you know
we know that um you know and spread of
information uh are sped up by having
these long ties
um and uh social contagions
characterized by a noisy threshold for
adoption also are sped up by them so
it's kind of this nice harmonization of
what seemed like these very different
models of spread
um and so it kind of give us a similar
story about uh what changes to network
structure would do
um uh these are the I didn't talk about
the third paper but these are the two
papers I talked about
um especially I was just talking about
the second one here I'm happy to stick
around for for comments or discussion or
get any of your feedback offline about
this as well
foreign
[Applause]
yeah we have some time for questions if
anyone has any any questions you can
navigate in the physical or virtual
world to the podiums to ask your
questions or the mics
Grant
yeah
I think you have to navigate to this
photo I'm sorry
I'm not sure this is a well-formed
question but I guess this idea of
reversion was kind of interesting to me
and
I wonder like if what kind of processes
we're thinking about if there's
processes of higher version like I get
into an exercise routine and I'm likely
to fall back if all things would would
change a strong price maybe or
useful alert if you think that's not not
quite the right story
yeah
um
yeah I think that's interesting cases
where it's very likely that people
revert
um yeah I think some of those it's hard
to if a virgin is high enough I guess I
guess maybe it's anything about okay
what's the part of the parameter space
where you have really higher immersion
and actually something is realistically
go into
spread very far
um now maybe that maybe that is
uh
possible right so I mean what will we
have in mind
reversion is lower when you have more
friends that are doing it
right your exercise routine I have 10
friends maybe
right right right and I think some of
that like I mean some of it we think
about reversion is just a way of upper
bounding to spread time for
re-evaluation so you could just think
you re-evaluate it and then you decide
to continue doing it you know if you
have at least Theta which on all the
examples I showed us two
um uh adopter friends
um
yeah
I guess I guess it you know
um it'd be interesting to see uh maybe
what additional evidence empirical
evidence we bring to bear on that
because thinking about like the
um uh the empirical evidence that we
have this for initial adoption there you
don't really see anything so striking in
that way but maybe there's something
about adherence it's interesting that's
a that's a good
maybe a good impetus to look at some of
the empirical stuff
I'm bahide has a question in the chat
it's the Facebook data during covid if
so is there any effect of difference in
the likelihood of remote work across
incomes
yeah it's interesting so so yes this is
yeah this is you know in something's
during covet
um you know
um I kind of wonder what what that
question is going to mean and you know
when people are asking me about 2022 I
don't know right anyway yes it is in the
period that you that you mentioned there
and um yeah I I think that we know that
that did change
um people's behavior online I think I
mean just drawing from like you know the
public reports uh from a bunch of the
social media companies said oh yeah like
usage is up Etc and
um so I would I would imagine that then
usage was up in a whole bunch of kind of
um
systematically kind of different uh
sorts of ways
um I didn't really go into this but we
do focus on on people here who at least
have some baseline level of usage and so
they have at least degree 10
um in this comment Network so that's
somewhat uh dealing with that then also
because we're conditioning on degree
that's also kind of like conditioning on
um this uh some measure of activity and
then finally in the analyzes involving
the weights that are like the counts of
comments that are exchanged we also are
conditioning that is like matching in
various ways on uh the sum of all of the
weights that is the just the total
number of comments that they produce
during that period of time or the total
yeah the total number of comments they
produce during that time so that um
you know it's in some way adjusting for
that but we didn't specifically look at
um
related to that um
um my my sense would be that a bunch of
this pattern would be kind of robust to
that period but certainly I think you
know be nice to have this be a kind of
rolling data set uh Our intention like
you know maybe not nearly as ambitious
as what um Matt Jackson and colleagues
did with the socialcapital.org
um is to make this geographically
aggregated data publicly available and
so then you know perhaps as part of that
it would be more something that could be
updated at Future times as well that
would be fantastic
great I think if there are no other
questions
I will just make a brief announcement
thanks Dean for for this fantastic talk
if you want to talk to Dean you know you
can
tune in the auditorium for those of you
that are
um in person in Berkeley I uh and but
you know virtually on on the platform if
you want to have lunch with other people
we can coordinate lunches uh by getting
into a group and discussing where to go
so I would recommend everybody that's
physically here and wants to join a
lunch group navigate to the uh your
avatar to the left uh there's a gray rug
and it says you are in the main seminar
room so if you can navigate navigate
your avatar to the sort of west side of
this room
um you can
uh coordinate lunch I see Ben golub is
already standing there
um
Courtney lunches
I'll watch you
and if you want to talk to Dean he's in
the table on in the south
east corner
I guess Ben doesn't want to go because
he's running away he's running over to
talk to Gene
this is fun it's like oh my God you know
what do they call those Sports
commentator from my sports commentator
for what's happening on the platform
foreign
I think poor Alex wants to go to lunch
with somebody nobody's and Alex why
don't you go to the table where Dean and
Ben are and see if you can convince them
to go to lunch
or uh yeah if you're around mute but did
anyone in this room want to go to lunch
with Alex
well I have a proposition I have a car
oh you can come up here I think Alex uh
wow that sounds fantastic